[Music]
all right let's get this party started
hello everybody I'm here to tell you
about time zones yeah I'm also surprised
that they accepted my talk maybe the
polers part of the title is what did it
either way it's quite a niche small
topic so that's why I think we can cover
everything there is to know about this
small topic cool I'm Marco gorelli I
work at quanite Labs I have about a day
a week on pandas a day a week on polers
and the rest of my time on assorted
projects such as the Consortium for
python data API standards which is
trying to improve interoperability
within the python data frame landscape
cool stuff how is today going to work
I'm going to start by making a
convincing case for why you should never
ever ever ever deal with time zones by
hand then going to give a quick crash
course on what you need to know about
poers to understand the rest of the talk
any polers users in the house tonight
woo got some but also some people not
putting their hands up so if you didn't
put your hand up that's fine you're
going to learn everything you need to
know to understand part three which is
polers and time zone specific things if
you did put your hand up then I hope
that I can still teach you something new
or a new way to think about polers and
expressions uh after that finally we've
got an engaging q& a and an awkward
silence it's up to you what the length
of X is uh Richie you missed me asking
people if they were polar's users but um
I was curious to see whether you'd put
your hand up redundantly or not either
way cool let's do this let's start with
part one why you should never ever ever
deal with time zones manually if you can
so let's have a another show of hands
any flat earthers in the house
tonight oh wow the Dutch education
system is really as good as people say
it is somehow I think if I was giving
this talk back at home in the UK at
least a few people would unironically
have put their hands up glad to see that
didn't happen here I'm not a flat
earther myself not a flat earther just
in case anyone was misunderstanding me
but I do see the appeal of this
conspiracy theory like I I do wish the
Earth was flat it would make so many
things much more simple like days would
always have 24
hours December the 30th would always
come after December the 29th yeah
believe it or not that's not always true
and uh scheduling recurring
cross-continent meetings would actually
be possible anyone who's tried doing
that will know it's it's you're going to
have at least a few weeks a year where
because of daylight savings time
somebody shows up somebody else shows up
an hour later that's that's just the way
it's going to be speaking of daylight
savings time let's uh introduce the
concept in the most British way possible
that is to say with a pub quiz so
suppose it's midnight on the 26th of
March 2023 here in the beautiful oven
and uh you then wait four hours what
time is
it okay in order to unlock the next
slide I'm going to need an answer from
the
audience 5
a.m it was either going to be 5 or 3
definitely not four so who said five
okay you win a polar sticker well
done and uh
yeah I'm impressed you were able to do
that in your head so let's learn about
why what is this nonsense tradition of
um disruptive scheduling tradition so
it's got two parts in October I think uh
Once Upon a Time somebody was enjoying a
party so much they decided they didn't
want to get up for work the next day so
when it got to 2: a.m. they figured yeah
let's go let's repeat this hour just so
good let's do it again and so the day
ended up having 25
hours uh so this unfortunately leads to
ambiguity like 2:15 what time is that
nobody knows if it's 1:45 and you're
waiting for somebody and they tell you
I'll be there at 2:15 you need to know
they're not necessarily half an hour
away they might be one and a half hours
away then in March we've got the
opposite problem somebody was evidently
very keen to get to work the next day
and just chopped off an hour so between
uh 2: a.m. and 3:00 a.m. didn't exist uh
this is a good way of sniffing out
stories if somebody's telling
you about an amazing thing they did at
2:30 a.m. on the 26th of March 2023 in
oven you need to know they are
bullshitting you that never happened
this daytime does not exist now you
might be thinking this is not that bad
like yeah sure it's confusing but at
least it's consistent like we just write
down a few rules this is when it changes
this is when it goes back and then we
can deal with it not that bad is it well
if there was at least some consistency
maybe it wouldn't be that bad
however let's take a look at what
happened in 2023 so on the 26th of March
here in Netherlands you skipped an hour
Meanwhile your American colleagues also
skipped an hour but they did it two
weeks early
then in most Asian countries and most
African countries they looked at DST and
were like yeah this is uh colonialist
we're not going to do this so
they don't observe DST at all uh but not
not not all of them like in Africa in
Morocco they actually do something like
daylight savings time except they do it
in the opposite direction than we do and
in the week between when we and
Americans do it just to add to the
confusion and then in just in case it
was wasn't bad enough Australia comes
along and in one of their time zones
because yes Australia has multiple time
zones in the same country they figured
let's let's move the clocks but on a
different day and let's also move them
by just half an hour not the full hour
absolute mess but again you might not be
convinced you might think I can you know
it's at least consistent year after year
I can just write this down a few if then
statements and it'll all be hunky dory
except in 2011 Samoa decided they would
change which time zone they were in they
were sick of being in UTC minus 10 and
decided they wanted to be in UTC plus4
so at uh nearly midnight on the 29th of
December one moment later it was the
31st of December the 30th of December
never happened if that was your
anniversary tough luck so I hope I've
made the convincing case that you should
never ever ever deal with time zones by
hand QED if you do you'll forget about
one of these subtleties like uh DST
cross country changes countries changing
their minds about
things so yeah don't do it instead use
polers so let's learn about polers
little super fast crash course
everything you need to know about polers
to understand how to deal with time
zones in polers let's get this party
started so the the most fundamental
object within polers is the data frame
data frame is just a collection of
columns each one of which holds some
elements which have to have a consistent
data type got lots of different data
types we're going to talk about them a
bit later but before we do let's talk
about Expressions let's learn about how
in the words of Dr Dre you can express
yourself a expression you can think of
it as a lazy column like a function like
if I make a function which uh is
something like uh if I take an input and
I double it
well what's the value of this function
it doesn't have a value until you give
it an input and similarly an expression
doesn't have a value until you give it a
data frame so if we write an expression
like pl. call a * 2 alos B it doesn't
have a value it's just a freestanding
function it Maps a data frame to a
column and once we put this in a data
frame context it will actually produce a
series most people don't really
necessarily think of it like this I
think most people just try using
Expressions find them quite intuitive
and don't stop to think about the fact
that they are functions maybe
technically they're not but this is how
I like to think about them so let's look
at an example this will make it very
intuitive to anyone who's not tried
using them before let's get started so
if we start with a beautiful data frame
like the one on top which has a single
column A with values one one and two we
can make a data frame just like that one
but with an extra column defined by the
expression I showed you before we just
take column a double all its values
rename rename it to B and there it is
well that was fun let's do it again
another example now we can use
inequality uh comparisons within our
Expressions so we can make Boolean masks
and then we can use these Boolean masks
to filter out certain rows like we want
to keep all rows where column A is
greater than one we just pass that to
filter and then filter will take our
data frame give it as input to the
expression and produce a data frame
which only keeps the rows where column A
is greater than one um are you missing
me talking about time zones yes I'm sure
you are so let's now talk about how this
helps us deal with time zones but first
we need
to talk about data types do you want a
bit of audience
interaction
woo pretty pumped up Dutch crowd so
going to read out a few data types and
I'd like you to give me a cheer when you
hear your favorite data type being read
out so let's start with
numeric okay got some data scientists
here in the front I presume okay
Boolean wow pretty Boolean reaction
there stayed s completely silent for the
first one and then hoot it out on the
second one cool understood the
assignment
string okay some NLP scientists down
there yes nice
categorical yeah maybe if I'd said it
with more enthusiasm I'd have got a few
more responses all right let's try
nested data types wo yeah there's
actually a talk on YouTube about why
somebody switched two polers and the
first number one reason they give is the
list data type it's truly phenomenal so
yeah look into it and then finally I
really like putting time zones on things
so my favorite data type is uh date time
because I can put a Time Zone on it but
that's not the only thing I can put on a
date time I can also put a Time unit so
let's learn what these two things are
and uh let's look at some examples so
first of all time unit this is just the
Precision so what's the smallest amount
of time that it can represent it can be
nanc microsc or the currently useless
millisecond on the other side of the
board we've got the time zone now this
can either be none and if you're lucky
enough to not have to think of time
zones then by all means set this to none
and keep living the dream but if you're
in the unfortunate situation where you
do need to think about time zones you'll
need to put something from the time zone
database so none of this uh like I don't
know abbreviations that could be
ambiguous you know Europe Amsterdam
Europe London Asia Katmandu that's my
favorite one you know put something
that's unambiguous and well
defined right why do we need a Time unit
let's uh take a a step back and revise
how date times are represented by
computers they're represented as the
amount of time since 197 1st of January
in Universal Coordinated
Time and uh just to prove to you that
I'm not lying I've uh made a little data
frame with a single date time which is
the 30th of November at 12 a.m. and I've
then shown the physical representation
of it on the right if we then take this
number and then add that number of
micros seconds to 1971 of January we
recover our original datetime so yeah
there I didn't lie to
you what about time zones time zones
actually modify these integer
representations of date times if we
compare the integer backing the same
time here in uh oven and that time in
Universal Coordinated Time then the
underlying time stamp are different and
if you subtract them and div and then
divide by the number of micros in an in
a in a second you should in or in an
hour sorry you'll get one because we are
currently one hour ahead of Universal
Coordinated Time cool stuff right let's
get on to the exciting part of the uh
presentation polers and time zones and
I'm going to start this by quoting from
the Zen of python you know we're Pi data
so I figure this uh is going to be
acceptable when I quoted from it at an R
conference last week didn't get a very
warm reception yeah joking of course I
didn't attend an our conference
so uh yeah the Z of python it says that
namespaces are one honking great idea
and uh python has excellent type hints
so use them to your advantage if you
just start typing an expression and then
type DT well DT is the namespace which G
gives you access to all of the functions
which work on temporal data types so if
you're looking for something just start
typing and then just scroll down scroll
through until you find something which
looks like it might be what you need
saves opening a separate tab right so if
we keep going for long enough you'll
find my favorite function in the world
replace time zone Let's uh let's look at
it in
action let's start with a data frame of
times here in the Beautiful oven and
then let's use replace time zone to
change the time zone both to uh UTC and
to Asia catmandu look isn't it beautiful
they are like 5 hours and 45 minutes
ahead of UTC I think they wanted that
when the sun was at the highest point it
would be directly over Mount Kilimanjaro
at some time of the year something like
that not sure what they're going to do
when tectonic shift means that that's no
longer the case but presumably by then
you'll all be using polers to do time
zone arithmetic for you so you won't
need to worry about
it and uh as you can see the local time
zones are the same so we haven't
actually changed the local time zones
here we've just changed the sorry we
haven't changed the local date times
we've just changed the time zone of them
but you might similarly be interested in
asking the question well if it's 1:00
a.m. here in oven what time is it for
our colleagues in Nepal and to answer
that question you're going to want to
use convert time zone and now this will
show you ah in Nepal it's
5:45 a.m. so when should you use one
when should you use the other if you're
trying to answer a question of the kind
what time is it now but somewhere else
convert time zone if you're trying to
answer a question what if it was this
local time but somewhere else then
replace time
zone now uh we had a pub quiz earlier
won by this gentleman in the front well
done so let's have another one I'm going
to ask you the same question but this
time the answer
is let's use polers let's see how polers
could have answered this question for us
but first I need to introduce to you the
amazing function offset by offset by
does what it says on the tin it'll take
a date time and then shift it forwards
by a certain Offset you can shift
forwards by days weeks months hours
milliseconds seconds and so on so we
want to shift forwards by four hours so
let's uh let's use that we're going to
start by creating a series with the 26th
of March we then localize it to Europe
Amsterdam and then we shift it forwards
by 4 hours and indeed we confirm that a
gentleman in the front was correct in
shouting out 5 a.m. well done now there
is a word of caution because I showed
show you before that we've got both D
and H and you might be thinking okay 1 D
24h same thing not
quite as you might have expected by now
this far in the talk One D just means
one calendar day so let's move to the
next day but at the same hour whereas 24
hours literally just means 24 hours it's
it's an ambiguous 24 hours yeah
so if we start on the 29th of October
midnight here in oven moving forwards 1D
shifts us to the 30th whereas moving
forwards 24 hours shifts us to 11: p.m.
which one do you want I think most of
the time you're probably going to want
One D so yeah just be mindful of the
difference and uh use the correct one
appropriately now whenever I talk about
time zones there's always some smarty
pants who comes up to me and says yeah
but we could just use UTC we don't need
time zones so let me dispel this myth
so why can't we just do everything in
UTC and then convert back well let's try
to do that suppose you've got some sales
data you've got some uh date times and
some numbers of sales and your boss asks
you okay please prepare me a report for
every day I want to know how many items
did we sell so if you just looked at
this you'd see okay well for the 29th of
November 1+ 3 + 1 if my maths is correct
that's five and then 30th of November
one however if you listened to smarty
pants on Reddit you would have converted
it to UTC you would have seen okay for
the 28th of November we've got one for
the 29th of November we've got four and
for the 30th of November we'd got one
and uh if your boss asks you why do you
have a data point for the 28th of
November I didn't even give you that in
my data set and you respond well someone
on Reddit told me to convert to UTC you
won't seem so smart so unfortunately
that's why we need to use uh time zones
also as I showed you earlier 1D isn't
always 24 hours and if you set the
correct local time zone then polers will
deal with this for
you unfortunately we don't always get
data fully formed in data frames the
world runs on csvs as demonstrated by
issue trackers and surveys so I'm going
to show you a super secret trick for
dealing with csvs and polers and that is
trass dates equals
true uh then po um poers will try to
infer the date format for you and then
it'll super efficiently pass the CSV
file um passing any column of strings
which corresponds to a date uh format as
a date time or as a
date uh it's it's more efficient than
first reading it a string and then
converting to a date or date
time but what if your CSV contains
offsets like plus two plus one and so on
and here polers does the same thing that
pyaro does uh gentle reminder polers is
not based on Pi
Arrow just thought I'd get that out
there to make Richie and the back smile
so the why does the conversion to UTC
happen why does polers not just like INF
further time zone for you automatically
from your data and the answer is it it
doesn't know I'll show you exactly what
I mean not in the next slide but in the
one after but first I'll tell you what
you can use to deal with this if you
know that your local time zone is say
Europe SL Amsterdam and that is you can
just specify that as the data type so
polite reminder date time we need to
specify two parameters which are the
time unit and the time zone us that is
micros seconds and then Europe SL
Amsterdam that is the time zone and if
we do that we do in indeed get some uh
date times which look like they really
did come from uh the Netherlands like
they all at uh they're all at midnight
and they change um offset when the
Netherlands observes daylight savings
time why couldn't polers do this for you
well let's have another pub quiz suppose
it's the 29th of October 2023 at
midnight
two hours ahead of
UTC if you wait for 24 hours what time
is your clock going to
show the answer is you don't know so
here in oven it would show you the it
would show you 1100 p.m. on the 29th of
October 1 hour ahead of UTC but in
Botswana it would show you the 30th of
October so you don't know polos will not
guess it for you and this will save you
a lot of headaches later in your
pipeline it's better if things work
predictably and consistently so convert
to UTC and then it's up to you to set
the time zone which you hopefully should
know that your data corresponds to so in
uh confusion what have we talked about
today first of all I hope I demonstrated
definitively to you that you should
never ever ever deal with time zones
manually if you can help it then we did
a very quick uh crash course on polers
learned the basics of how to work with
it and deal with date times and then
finally we learned about time zones in
poers about how One D is one calendar
day and 24h is 24 hours we learned about
the difference between replace time zone
and convert time zones for changing
between time zones and then we learned
about how passing offset aware strings
in when reading a CSV file will result
in UTC time zone and it's up to you to
set the time zone which you hopefully
know that your data corresponds to anden
you've been absolutely fantastic now
please go out and convert some time
zones I've been Marco please pip install
poers have a great time at the rest of
your conference respect the code of
conduct get in contact if you want some
training and please ask any questions
thank
you all right not all at
once uh yeah so how do you deal with um
ambiguity in offset offsets for dat
times which you often run into with
pandas if you say I want one month in
the future yeah how many days is that
month uh that's a great question so
calendar is a so month is one calendar
month so if you start like on the
31st of January and you add one month
that goes to the 28th or the 29th of of
February depending on the year so it it
literally it's not a fixed quantity it
will just increment the month by one and
then saturate to the largest date in
that month if uh if the particular month
if if the particular date you're trying
to get to does not
exist
January February exactly yeah
and
February that sounds
right you can if you want
to got a few here
um unless it's a leapia yeah thought you
were so smart didn't
you all right got a question there
towards the
back
can you start the year not on the
January the 1 can I start the year not
on January the 1 and it may be a stupid
question but we deal with seasonality in
our data so we want to have at January 1
in the middle of our graphs rather than
at the beginning or the end so can you
give me an example of an operation which
you'd want to do because for just a
basically visualization already so tin
my colleague solved this now I think I
think you did it manually
uh so uh polas itself does not do
visualization you have to use I
understand
okay uh sorry I yeah don't worry okay
well to try to interpret the question so
if you're doing the same thing is if you
if you work in the financial world and
the year ends at uh the 30th of November
you have the same thing oh okay sure so
let's say if you want to find let's say
the total by year then can can you set
year to start at a different point all
right cool uh so the the function for
resampling by year in polers is called
Group by Dynamic so in that one you can
specify uh how often you want your
groups to start so you could specify
that to be one year but then if I
remember correctly there's also an
offset parameter so you could set the
offset to be whatever you want such that
then the first of January ends up where
you wanted to be so if you look in the
docs there's the exact formula for how
the groups are created and by combining
every period and offset I'd like to
think that you'd be able to uh represent
whatever exact period you want uh I'm
going to take the chance to self-promote
here because if you need to specifically
deal with business days so if you want
logic to say skip weekends or skip
holidays then you can use a polar plugin
called polers SL bus which will deal
with those complexities for you and if
any of this is not
addressed if any of this isn't addressed
uh if it's yeah not easy please uh do
join the Discord Super Active join the
ISS uh open an issue on GitHub uh if it
can't be done then yeah would' be very
interested in trying to make it easy for
people after all the shared goal is to
change the world using the power of
polers and uh we can do that more easily
if uh we've got clear
requests
right got 3 minutes left I think yeah
any other questions just start yeah in
the back all right still got questions
more interest than I thought in time
zones good to
see uh who had a question thought
everybody would be going to the pixie
talk thanks for coming can you pass uh
different time zones so because you show
the example where you specify the time
zone but if you have different time
zones that's uh yeah so in this example
we've got different offsets within the
same
file uh but but because it was the same
time zone yeah exactly so if you had
like uh plus two and then plus one and
then plus three or something that's a
lot trickier because in polers each
column has to have a specified time zone
so what polos would do here is it would
convert everything to UTC and if you've
got different offsets I would hope that
you've also got a column telling you
what local time zone that came from so
then you could partition your rows based
on that other column and then convert
each one to its local time zone but yeah
you'd have to do it in two steps there
was actually a feature request recently
about being able to do this in a single
step within lazy with with a lazy frame
so being able to use lazy computation
for this it's currently not possible but
I think it's a reasonable feature
request so hopefully we'll be able to
find a solution for this either in a
Plugin or in poas
itself okay final question well it's
more of a personal question how can I
develop your um showman presentation
skills and be in the same time zone as
you uh sure so uh Step One is uh when
you're 18 have the bad idea of thinking
that in life you want to be a musician
and then uh perform in pubs and
experience nobody paying attention to
you and learn that if you want to catch
people's attention you need to really
ask for it and uh provide a bit of
entertainment and then number four burn
out and become a data
scientist okay thank
you okay thank you Marco for the very
energetic talk oh thank you
[Music]
that's